BY ANTHONY.
>> HARRIS, DEFENSE, JACKSON.
>> CHECK THE BALL MOVEMENT.
>> 5 TO GO.
REGGIE FOR THE LEAD.
OH, HOT DAMN WHAT A SHOT.
REGGIE JACKSON!
ARE YOU READY FOR YOUR
CLOSE-UP?
[ CROWD CHEERING ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> YOU SEE THIS TEAM, THIS
UNIT OF THE CLIPPERS, THEY ARE
PULLING FOR EACH OTHER.
LUKE KENNARD ONE OF THE FIRST
GUYS CONGRATULATING REGGIE, 3
OF 8 FROM THE THREE-POINT
LINE.
LUKE, 7 OF 11, OFF TWO
SCREENS, IS THERE A SWITCH,
YES THERE IS, A FAKE LEFT,
STEPS BACK RIGHT, KNOCKS DOWN
THAT SHOT.
AND A WIDE-OPEN LOOK, A
TWO-POINTER.
BUT I THOUGHT IT WAS A THREE,
IT'S ONLY A TWO.
>> ORLANDO HAS A CHANCE TO
PULL IT OUT WITH 2.2 IT PLAY.
THAT SAID, WE POINTED IT OUT
EARLIER, REGGIE HAS GIVEN YOU
EVERYTHING HE HAS EVERY SINGLE
NIGHT.
[ CROWD NOISE ]
[ BUZZER ]
>> TODAY IN THE FOURTH
QUARTER, A WIZARD, HE HAS NINE
OF HIS 25 IN THE FINAL FRAME.
AND POTENTIALLY A GAME-WINNER,
THE CLIPPERS NEED TO DEFEND,
WITHOUT FOULING.
[ BUZZER ]
>> REMEMBER, HE SHOT THAT
OVER, THE HEAD OF JUNIOR.
6'10", CREATED THE SPACE, A
MOVE TO THE LEFT, A STEP-BACK
TO THE RIGHT.
PLENTY OF TIME.
>> WELL, COLE ANTHONY CAN GET
THE JOB DONE, CLIPPERS CANNOT
LOSE SIGHT OF HIM.
2.2 TO PLAY.
>> WATCH THIS, AFTER HE PASSES
IF HE CUTS AND MOVES WITHOUT
IT.
>> LOOKING FOR THE STOP.
THE THREE FOR THE WIN?
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
[ CROWD NOISE ]
>> 106-104, CLIPPERS HOLD ON!
REGGIE JACKSON!
PUTS THE CLIPPERS OUT IN
FRONT.
FOR GOOD!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
[ CROWD NOISE ]
♪ ♪
>> JUST A GREAT EFFORT ....
COACHING STAFF, PLAYERS, TO
WIN WITH THIS GAME, ORLANDO
PLAYE